[Musik]
quirlig und herzlich willkommen hier am
truppenübungsplatz in ein stück mein
name ist wortmann kaufmann manuel von
institut panzerwagen in zwölfaxing der
heeresgruppe schule und die mächtigkeit
der business überwachungssystem leopard
2 4 erklären ich würde sagen wir
brauchen ein kleiner rundgang kommt es
mit grundsätzlich unterscheidet man den
leopard roman der turm und unten haben
wir die wanne
wir haben forderte schwan ketten blenden
roten haben wir eine gleis gliederkette
die gleiche lied erklärte wiegt ungefähr
zweieinhalb tonnen ist vergleichbar mit
andrea griff da haben wir unseren dank
der tank oder fassungsvermögen von 1000
160 liter
es ist ja relativ sparsames fahrzeug wir
verbrauchen ungefähr 3,4 liter auf
kilometer schauen wir mal weiter
wir haben daher unsere leichten ketten
blenden die hintere leichte captain
blende ist auf klopft damit wir uns
einfach nicht selber im dreck ins
laufwerk zahlen und dann im endeffekt
die kette herunter fahren wird und dann
harten wurf und dann heißt es wieder
unsere kraken
wir haben den antriebs zahnradantrieb
zahnkranz heute im endeffekt die einzige
aufgabe
er schaut dass die kraft vom motor mit
1500 ps auf die kette kommt schon mal
weiter dahinten das ist das sogenannte
heck von banzer das heckrotor die
auspuff trainings mit den abschlepp
zählen hin und wieder kommt es ja doof
nur dass er der panzer festfährt und für
das haben die abschleppseil dass sie da
japan zu den anderen bands aber kostet
sie ihn kennen
da würde dann gehen wir weiter zur
linken seite des kampfpanzers team
effekt identisch zur rechten zeit ist
bis auf eine kleinigkeit wir haben dort
die abc schutz und belüftungsanlage abc
für wo steht das abc steht für atomar
biologisch chemisch kampfstoffe das
heißt sollte irgendein chemischer oder
biologischer angriff stattfinden mit
kampfmitteln bahn haben wir dort die
anlage die im endeffekt dafür da ist
dass wir die csu auf
sitzen müssen sondern können im
endeffekt die einschritten und brauchen
eben diese abc schutzmaske oder andere
schutzausrüstung nicht und jetzt würde
sagen war dort bei der einstiegshilfe
und ausstiegshilfe sahen setzen auf und
sagen was das ganze format passt jetzt
befinden wir uns am kampfpanzer mehrere
kurze bisserl erklären wie viele
besatzungsmitglieder am korb panzer
leopard 2 4 sahen und wurde überhaupt
alle sitzen rechts unter mir das einzige
besatzungsmitglied los in der wanne
sitzt ist der vor
dahinter haben wir den rechtsschutz der
was dort durch das e mails durchschaut
das ist eine 12 fache vergrößerung mit
einem werbebild dazu der richter hat
ebenso die aufgabe zu schießen
beziehungsweise generell gegen turm zu
schwenken
hinter dem rechtsschützen sitzt akkurat
dass ich bin in dem vor der kamera
antwort die aufgabe den panzer zu führen
und natürlich sich morgen im gelände zu
orientieren
links und komponenten sind salate
schütze der lade schütze lebt die
bordwaffen und in einer
betriebsunterbrechung kuchen wurden
kaffee passt der gema war dazu die
bordwaffen die haupt bewaffnung des
leopard 2 4 ist die 120 mm banzer
klapdor kanone
wir haben zwar verschiedene
munitionsarten dkm zdk es im endeffekt
hast kinetische energie ziersdorf andere
kauft panzer die mz fürs dorf weitere
ziele oder vielleicht gepanzerte ziele
außerdem hat jedes besatzungsmitglied zu
wie man es bei mir deutscher sicht eine
p80 mit links von der 120 mm
panzerkanonen haben wir koaxial
eingesetzt das 7 62 millimeter fn marke
finnmark dieser belgisches
maschinengewehren was hats koaxial
koaxial es im endeffekt nichts anderes
wie das im endeffekt die kanone mit dem
mg auf eine höher ist und wie genau die
chancen wo der rechtsschütze geschaut
das wars natürlich nur nett wir gingen
dann weiter nach hinten
und das ist das maschinengewehr von
lauda schützen
das sind 162 maschinengewehr von der
firma fn marx wird eingesetzt für die
flaggen sicherung und kann auch im
vertrieb eingesetzt werden
außerdem haben auf beiden seiten am heck
des turmes eine mehrfach wurfanlage die
mehrfach wurfanlage korn im endeffekt
uns vor uns eine nebelwand bilden das
wir dahinter ungedeckt verschwinden
verschwinden können
und zu guter letzt schauen wir jetzt nur
in band seine jetzt befinden wir uns am
laden schützenplatz die hauptaufgabe von
lars schütze ist das laden der bord
warfen wie funktioniert das lohner
wurde.foto haupt worten wir haben hinter
mir
der mond punkt tourmo punkt kann 15
schuss eine london nimmt dann dallas
schütze die munition wasser und ladet
sie hier
inter kann ohne dass seine mehr effekte
hauptaufgaben von lore schützen und
jetzt schauen wir natürlich schützen
erst jetzt kann man recht schützenplatz
die hauptaufgabe des rechts schützen ist
das schwenken des turmes und das führen
des vorkampfes der richter kann den
vorkampf in der bis zu einer
geschwindigkeit von 50 km h in der vaart
schießen und trifft genau ins ziel und
war dadurch schützen schießen darf
das sollte ein kamerad dem blatt schauen
wir sie jetzt da jetzt sah man platz von
quadraten der command führt die
besatzung und den kampfpanzer außerdem
hat der kommandant doch eine eigene
optik mit einer unabhängig vom richter
schützen beobachten kann
außerdem kann er die kanone übernehmen
und den vorkampf selbst führen und jetzt
zu guter letzt schon zum voraus
passt jetzt haben im vorraum der panzer
los im endeffekt foren wie automatik
auto apropos banzer der ganze hat nur
für eine panzerung von 90 cm für links
die bremsen und rechts des gas und
apropos gas jetzt mir zwar gas geben bei
unseren anderen drei blocks auf der
schießbahn den worten chance
[Musik]